الزلزال الذي تسبب بازمه انسانيه ما يزال
ياخذ مستويات اسوا والامم متحده قد فعلت
ما بوسعها لتكون على حجم الاستجابه فنحن
نقوم بنشر خبراء لتقييم الاضرار ونعمل على
التنسيق مع فرق الاغاثه وتامين المواد
الطبيه وبعض المواد الاخرى الموقده للحياه
واننا ملتزمون بفعل المزيد ولهذا السبب
فانني كنت قد طلبت من وكيل لغات الانسانيه
ليسافر الى المناطق المتضرره باسرع ما
يمكن وهو قد وصل الى تركيا وسوف يزور غازه
عنتاب حلب ودمشق للوقوف على الاحتياجات
ومعرفه كيف لنا ان نقوم بزياده دعمنا
من اجل تقديم هذه المساعدات اننا بحاجه
الى امرتين الى امرين اولا قدره الوصول
فالناس يموتون وهذا هو الوقت
لاستكشاف وكافه السبل الممكنه التي يمكن
من خلالها بلوغ كافه المناطق اننا بحاجه
لانقاذ ارواح البشر ثانيا المصادر ان
صندوق الاعانات
بحاجه الى دعم على الحدود السوريه
والخيارات الافضل هي من خلال شركاء الامم
المتحده الذين لابد لهم ان يهبوا لمساعده
الناس قد تم تحرير 25 مليون دولار لهذا
صندوق كبدايه لكن في مطلع الاسبوع القادم
سوف نقوم باطلاق مناشده للدول الماني حرب
سوف تخصص لهؤلاء الذين تضرروا في سوريا
كما قلت لكم فان الامم المتحده بالعمل مع
منظمات غير الحكوميه تعمل على الاستجابه
في سوريا وتقوم بتقييم المتطلبات الاوليه
للاشهر الثلاثه القادمه هذه المصادر
والمعر سوف تستخدم ومن قبل المنظمات
الانسانيه من اجل
الحاجات الاساسيه مثل الماوى والتدفئه
وغيرها من
المتطلبه الرئيسيه وكذلك ايضا سوف نقوم
بدعم
المتطلبات في تركيا باسرع ما يمكن في في
وجه هذه الكارثه غير المسبوقه فانني اهيب
بالاسره الدولي ان تظهر لتركيا وسوريا
نفسي نوع الدعم الذي كانوا قد قدموه في
مساعده وحمايه ملايين اللاجئين
والنازحين في اظهار كبير للتضامن الان هو
وقت اظهار التضامن مع الشعبين السوري
والتركي
شكرا جزيلا
لدي سؤالا السؤال الاول هل تعتقدون انه
يجب ان يكون هناك المزيد من
المعابر الحدوديه التي يجب فتحها فضلا عن
باب الهوى
ثانيا لابد لمجلس الامن ان يصدر بيانا
حوله هذه الكارثه او ان يناقش الامر هل
لديكم اي تعليق بهذا الشان هذه لحظات وحده
وليست اللحظات لتسيس الامر او للفرقه لكن
من الواضح اننا بحاجه الى دعم كبير لدى
فانني سوف اكون سعيدا اذا ما كان مجلس
الامن سوف يتوصل الى اصدار بيانا او قرار
لفتح المزيد من المعابر الحدوديه كما اننا
بحاجه لزياده قدراتنا لتقديم العمليات عبر
الخطوط في ادلب
وصولا الى دمشق
الحكومه السوريه
سعاده الامين العام تقول بان كافه
المساعدات يجب ان تنطلق
بدءا من دمشق وعبر الخطوط هل هذا كافن
المساعدات عبر الخطوط تعد مهمه لكن
الكارثه هي اكبر باننا لدرجه اننا بحاجه
للمساعدات عبر الحدود وعبر الخطوط وهذه
المسائل يجب ان لا تسيس هذه لحظات يجب لنا
ان نعمل سويه من اجل دعم المتضررين وكما
قلت لكم ان الناس كانوا
قد اظهروا حسا من الكرامه
[موسيقى]
والضيافه التي لا تضاعها عندما استقبلوا
عددا كبيرا من اللاجئين من سوريا وتركيا
والعراق